president john f kennedy's all-too-brief
life was documented like none before in
photos that helped build the image of a
young leader with more than a touch of
glamour this year to mark the 100th
anniversary of his birth many of these
images are being shown in an exhibition
now touring the country which just
opened here in New York and not what
your country can do for you ask what you
can do for your country
john f kennedy's 1961 inauguration
address remains one of the most
memorable moments in American history
shortly before those historic remarks
Kennedy and his wife Jackie were all
smiles as they made their way from the
snowy White House to the Capitol this
picture is part of a new exhibit at the
New York Historical Society Museum
showing Kennedy's public and private
moments what you see in this exhibit is
not JFK as a politician not JFK winning
an election or making a point in
Congress or giving a speech but you see
him as a father Yunus grandmother my
mother
Stephen Kennedy Smith jr. is a cousin of
the 35th president and co-author of JFK
a vision for America which includes
everything from drafts of speeches to
over 500 photographs of Kennedy we went
through 34,000 photos from America's
greatest documentary photographers and
put them together into the book and the
exhibit some of the photographs reveal
the weight of Kennedy's public life like
this one of a pained president hunched
over the Oval Office desk while others
show quieter moments like this 1958
photo showing Kennedy beside his infant
daughter Caroline or this snapshot from
the 1960 presidential campaign showing a
group of young admirers looking on as
Kennedy worked on a speech it also
covers the devastation following
Kennedy's assassination capturing a
glimpse of Jackie on the day of her
husband's state funeral a hope is that
visitors will come away with new insight
into one of the most captivating
presidents in history I want them to be
intrigued I want them to be inspired I
want them to be curious and I want them
to read
Kennedy's words and that's really the
whole point of this project the exhibit
opened yesterday in New York it's also
running at the Smithsonian Art Museum
until September 7th here through January
7th and if people want to learn more
about it we have on our CBS this morning
Instagram page sort of taking you
through the life of JFK some amazing
pictures though that I had not seen
before
yeah it's interesting I think he was the
first president who is really
photographed as in you know as intensely
as as this it's just incredible
documents you feel like you were there
and living some of those moments